gerade ihr trainer alter diese visa
legten denn auch während es auf dem fuß
ich finde daran sieht man auch wirklich
ja wie schon gesagt was wir wirklich
viel einfluss haben das heißt auch wenn
dir ein paar meinungen sage ich mal
vertreten wie jetzt hier eine ganz
abstrakte meinung sagen sag ich mal
irgendwie äußern zum beispiel ich fände
es nicht rassistisches sein das wären
jetzt als es in den sinn gekommen aber
ihn wie so was ich zum beispiel ja ich
sag jetzt einfach jahr der der hitler
der war schon ganz cool nur als wenn mir
sowas sagen das ist jetzt natürlich nein
war natürlich nicht aber wenn wir so was
du im ernst sagen dann wird das
natürlich von vielen aufgenommen wenn
wir das sagen hätte das gut vielleicht
können ja manche hitler so gar nicht
obwohl es eigentlich allgemeinwissen ist
aber ich denke ja wenn die das sagen war
das schon so und dann haben wir halt
wirklichen einfluss auf die kinder
die leute die unsere videos gucken und
deswegen müssen wir mittlerweile seien
die austritte gucken zu vielen zu großen
teilen sich natürlich auch nicht davon
beeinflussen lassen das möchte jetzt mal
logisch dass ich viele von euch nicht
durch sowas beeinflussen lassen was wir
sagen aber es sind halt auch viele
zuschauer insbesondere glaube ich die
comments viele von den
kommentarschreibern oder der großteil
kommentar schreibe auch nicht alle sind
häufig halt auch mit ihrer natürlich und
dann lässt man sich durch sowas leicht
beeinflussen seien preise wenn ihr
zurück denken beeinflussen wenn ihr
zurück denn wenn ihr wenn ihr zwölf
jahre alt war oder vielleicht zeigt hier
ist ja noch nicht mal oder seit ist
gerade aber der lässt man sicherheit die
dies die es noch nicht sind oder dies
gerade sind die werden dann später
merken ja mein gott da habe ich mich
früher leicht beeinflussen lassen
ja ja das kann ich jetzt eigentlich auch
einfach nur so unterstreichen weil es
ist einfach so das sieht man auch schon
in den kommentaren was da manchmal so
gefragt wird was da so ich sage mal
manchen leuten und jetzt beleidigend zu
sein das ist jetzt natürlich nicht gegen
dich der das video gerade sieht sondern
einfach mal so allgemein gefasst es gibt
ein paar kommentare wie zum beispiel
erst da und damit 100 ha am ende unter
1000 ausrufezeichen und als die zeugen
nicht so von ganz großer intelligenz ist
ohne das internet nicht intelligent aber
wenn 11 11 hinter steht schon wenn elf
hinter steht es wieder quelle dena du
bei mir
jedenfalls was soll ich jetzt sagen ja
genau solche leute kann man relativ
leicht beeinflusst das heißt egal was
wir sagen die glaubens und die nehmen
uns ab weil wir halt vorbilder für die
sind sie sehen dann auch teilweise in
uns sage ich mal so ihre vorbilder idole
sage ich mal und das damit müssen wir
quasi lernen umzugehen sei
weil wir natürlich diesen entwürfen
diesen einfluss nicht ausnutzen ganz
einfach also habe ich auch eine sache
von mir selber das ist länger mal her da
habe ich noch let's play auf youtube
gefunden also das konnte man schon fast
nicht ernst nehmen das war nicht so das
übliche was man zu den klischees hört
von handycam und fernseher wo man in der
spiegelung noch kinderzimmer sieht oder
sowas sondern es wirklich schon so
extrem also dass ich konnte endlich
konnte das eigentlich nicht fassen da
habe ich aus spaß einfach mal so auf
twitter gepostet er der schlechteste
let's player der welt und wurde dann von
bombay damals ordentlich zurecht
gewiesen was mir eigentlich einfällt
dass ich mich im reißen könnte mit
meiner reichweite hin zu gehen und
jemanden als schlechtesten let's play
der welt abzusterben euro legt ok
scheiße hast du eigentlich recht hat
dann auch alles sofort gelöscht war
irgend nur fünf minuten lang online
deswegen kennt es wahrscheinlich auch
keiner aber es ist einfach so man hat
eine gewisse verantwortung die wir
natürlich auch viel viel größer man hat
sondern seine reichweite und sein
einfluss ist kann man ganz einfach sagen
wenn das thema gerade so gut dass ich
beschlossen habe wir sprechen dass in
dieser folge weiter ja das hat gesagt
felix rechtsrutsch 1 17 minuten den wir
wollten nur 13 minuten jetzt ein thema
für kanada gar nicht dass er jetzt noch
13 minuten folgen einer wm ist ja
manchmal wieso 20 video in folge gehabt
und irgendwo 15 machen das ist einfach
weil man massen schneiden muss wegen
thema damit es passt sage ich mal damit
dann ist noch immer das nächste thema
als und vor allem auch mit intro auto
das sieht auch noch mal lockten minute
anderthalb minuten
deswegen wir wollen die folgen wegs über
15 minuten belassen und ja das heißt
laut sagen wir 30 minuten
apropos einfluss da kann ich auch ne
story erzählen und zwar ich weiß gar
nicht ob ich die ich hab dich schon mal
in dem layer mir erzählt aber da ihr
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht mehr das
playstation blog ein stück alles so bei
dir gleich das echt so viele computer
schreibst naja gehabt ihr mit schere
damit ein paar schafe und schafen
vielleicht findest du in einer meiner
thron in meinem haus at alleine aber mit
zwei brauchst du nur zwei eisen
also vielleicht hat mir nicht also
entweder meinem haus einen lukas
ausbildung eine schere
ok ich suche mal euer haus matadors
gibt's jetzt habe ich kaputt da isch
kandidiere bei euch selber ich muss
selber ganz ganz viel wurde für eine für
eine dinge nicht bauen wollte in borno
berechnung ziehen wolle oder sowas
auf solche geben ich habe ihm die zehen
stacks oder so ja natürlich vor allem
jetzt erst mal hin erhöht
hallo hallo hier diamanten so und zwar
wollte ich eine story erzählen aus dem
vorjahr bzw
ich war nicht im urlaub weilt in den
ferien eine freundin von mir war im
urlaub auf mallorca mit ihrer familie
die hat eine kleine schwester und die
kleinen schwester also meine freundin
die ist 16
das ist nicht meine freundin sondern
seine freunde nicht dass es jetzt viele
wieder falsch versteht man ja immer zu
sagen jedenfalls ihre schwester durch 13
man halte am urlaub und dann war da
wirklich eine person als sie das halt im
restaurant der am frühstückstisch und
eine person neben den war so war wie alt
die person war ich würd sagen
12 13 klopp schon jedenfalls haben die
sicherheit über bronk unterhalten diese
person mit seinem freund jeder auch auf
mallorca war und dann kommt so meine
freundinnen an also eine freundin von
mir kommt dann halter anderem ein tor
die weisheit auch dass ich so videos der
macht und sagt ja ich kann auch so ein
jeder heißt konkret werde man zu videos
wenn er so was er sagt du kennst und der
ist richtig ausgerastet eine der meist
sofas kennst du den wirklich und so und
ich konnte mir das halt gar nicht
vorstellen dass da einer so ausrastet
nur weil jetzt mich kennen und dann
quasi eine bekanntschaft von mir
persönlich trifft
und der hat mich danach in der facebook
gerettet und bleiben damit
haben geschrieben und das ist echt
heftig was für ein einfluss man hat dass
man quasi eine freundin von mir
trifft eine person auf mallorca hat die
meine videos sieht das ist schon
irgendwie kraft hat mich dann erstmal
richtig geflasht ich weiß da habe ich
auch noch was für dich und zwar habe ich
vor kurzem was heißt der kurs pro monat
oder sowas habe ich gleich jetzt mein
haus rein wir müssen nämlich wieder
schlafen habe ich sicher nicht schlafen
ich glaube ich dann gewiss sein könnte
schlafen ich bin irgendwo der höhle okay
was uns erzählt hat habe ich mich mit
glaube ich kindern von geschäftskollegen
kann meinem vater da irgendwie sowas
unterhalten und dann hab ich gemein oder
an ich hab ich mit denen unterhalten
genau da hat er gemeint let's play
station meinen kindern
die kennen nämlich auch minecraft und so
habe ich mich mit leuten die 30 jahre
älter sind wie ich über minecraft noch
unterhalten sogar bis zum bett fertig
geht sofort ins bett und da habe ich
später noch mit den kindern gesprochen
die bahnen irgendwie so im bereich von
12 und 14 jahren sage ich mal und habe
dann gesagt der alex paisley so cool wie
viele opfer es hassen und so habe ich
ein bisschen mit dem einen kanal gerät
schlage mich mit dir schlafen könnten
und dann habe ich dieses gekommen habe
ich gesagt ja vielleicht kennt er mich
aber irgendwelche kollegen von mich bei
meinen kanal haben sie nicht gekannt
habe ich leute genannt mit dem ich etwas
gemacht haben und rat mal wählen sie
gekannt haben mich ja
ernst gemeint habt ihr trauminsel
gesehen weil das erst zwei wochen nach
traum was wir dann habe ich den part
gesehen dass irgendwie das war dann so
richtig krass weil ich finde sowieso
immer kraft im reallife unterwegs bist
und dann leute von youtube also dass es
irgendwie mir hat aber studium hat auch
gerade ein kollege von mir von der woche
oder so gesagt ja bei mir zu hause
gibt's einen der kunde eine videoseite
den ich muss noch crisp entgegne ich bin
aufgestanden
ich finde es auch immer total krass wenn
du dann hingehst und werde ich ja tag
ist und dann einfach das ist irgendwie
das sind zwei welten die eigentlich
irgendwie nicht zusammen gehören das ist
so da merkt man wieder was für ein
einfluss man hat hh thema übergreifend
wie ein freund hat einer von euch news
am montag
hat einer von euch clay nein und ich bin
happy house ist ein fluss und da ist was
und ich höre zombie das war ja wirklich
auf dem feld man immer schon ein ja den
hat mir zu einfach sagen dass man gar
keine story so erzählt kann ich machen
aber was ist gerade mit uneingeweihten
ja gar nix also ich habe nicht alle vier
wollen verdammt vier wolle
ok hat mich wahrscheinlich nicht
vertreten
april update abbrechen abbrechen bringen
da nur der dena der leg grad echt ein
bisschen affleck gerade ihr training
alter alter wiese wie soll denn auch
während es aufnehmen so bescheuert auf
jeden fall noch am donnerstag und damit
schon 21 uhr
dann sagt er bescheiden
ein anderes mal auf oder so alt aber
wäre das auch eine kurzfristig das kenne
ich auch das habe ich mir einmal gemacht
und dann hat ging echt gar nichts hier
sei also rennt dann konnte ich bin 50k
internet dann wäre das aus anderen
ländern kannst dir weil du ein stellen
kannst das höhere priorität haben kann
oder nur an einzelne kerne bin aber
hochladen ist das andere aber man hat
laden
dann braucht man so ein tool zum
hochladen deshalb den netzwerkverkehr
regelt das jetzt skype und minecraft
vorrang haben vor dem browser mit dem
upload hast du das so ein programm das
wäre praktisch weil dann könnte man aber
gut steht jetzt die sich wundern warum
meine donnerstags videos im erste um 23
30 kommen
ich komme aus der schule und dann
erstmal keinen bock also dann wenn man
nach der schule immer so total leer so
schon wieder nichts gelernt
schüler halt und überall zombies aber
ich finde ich wo ich hin muss
naja und dann das bestimmt schon länger
nach erholungs rate das ist immer noch
das von vorhin aber nach zwei stunden
fängt man an zu das video zu machen und
dann wird immer länger da muss man stein
und es wird immer länger erzählt sie
immer länger hin
dann ist schon 19 uhr und da wollen wir
um 19 uhr aufnehmen habe mich noch 20
uhr verschoben
und dann habe ich ja fertig gerendert
das video das während der ersten zwei
folgen jetzt hochladen aber es geht
nicht das heißt wenn fertig aufgenommen
haben dann läuft das halt ich hätte das
video kommt und 23 uhr 25
aber nagelt mich nicht darauf fest ich
schätze das video kommt wenn ihr diese
folge gerade seht vor ungefähr einer
woche lief ungefähr vier tagen oder so
am donnerstag
am donnerstag haben es passt ja gut wir
sind es schon wieder bei 26 minuten der
däne selbst wenn man 13 wir würden dann
jetzt schon wieder mit neuen thema
anfang mai sekunden das heißt wir jetzt
schon schon noch noch eine neue folge in
der 2
und übrigens auch das wollte ich noch
ganz genau ebendieser folge sagen wir
haben uns mal kommentare angeguckt
beziehungsweise bei den er in dem tollen
forum da wo ich eigentlich auch manchmal
sehr aktiv bin manchmal ist sehr aktiv
komische zusammenstellen das schneide
ich einfach raus damit ihr keine wird
der begriff und zwar kam die frage auf
warum streitet ihr euch immer bla bla
rasch erfolgt und schon abgefunden
das ist nämlich genau der grund weil
lena gold gefunden hat und das geht
nicht auf
naja jedenfalls wir streiten uns erstens
nicht und zweitens habt ihr doch gewollt
dass wir ein bisschen träumen wir uns
alles wieder falsch also das versteh
nicht mal wir haben euch ja die
möglichkeit gegeben zu entscheiden sage
ich mal
deswegen werden wenn es ein bisschen ist
das okay aber ich würde sagen wir machen
das jetzt erstmal ein bisschen wieder so
dass wir jetzt erholen quatschen bauen
weil das finde ich besser englisch
persönlich auch besser sein haus ich
mochte dein haus ein ja ich mache mein
haus auch nicht so dass so abgerissen
bocker etwas anderes paar leuten und
mich mit 55 leveln töten daher etwas
anderes du da das andere das level
müssen verdichtet sein da die vorherige
million gepackt ich nicht interessiert
kommt wieder ein thema geklärt